[Musique]
en avant première ses invités découvrent
la nouvelle programmation des théâtres
départementaux
une rentrée artistique est euphorique
décalé souriante et avant tout
surprenante pour les mois de février à
septembre 2018 nouvelle programmation
qu'elle est encore à l'image de satie
elle c'est à dire qu'elle est multiple
et elle fera dialoguer des artistes de
la réunion qui sont là depuis un long
moment et qu'on aime autant comme michou
et je l'aurai t aussi jules jacques
julien beaucoup de textes très roll en
français sur la manche la manche la vie
sur notre état d'âme sur tout ce qui est
culturel de la réunion on vend aux
défendre vraiment patrimoine quoi une
programmation qui ambitionne d'ouvrir la
scène un plus large public leur faire
prendre conscience de l'existence de la
culture et leur faire découvrir les
artistes qui ont développé cette
perfection de la ne voulait enfin c'est
surtout c'est très important à travers
une volonté réaffirmée soutenu
décentraliser la culture je trouve que
vraiment il ya un très beau panel de
e
deux spectacles qui est offert aux
réunionnais sur ces deux sites mais
aussi sur d'autres sites parce qu'ils
sont ils ont un partenariat avec
d'autres théâtres de la réunion est
vraiment c'est
de belles représentations
vraiment qui sont proposés il ya aussi
une mise en valeur des artistes
réunionnais on peut dire que dans ce
panel de propositions qui est fait dans
le programme 2018
on a vraiment de théâtre à la réunion
qu'ils sont dignes de théâtre du monde
des virtuoses de la musique du spectacle
de la danse et de la comédie seront à la
fiche de cette rentrée et rendez vous
incontournables comme le taux total et
la 11e nuit des virtuoses font également
la part belle à cette programmation
[Musique]